my name is Chris Hadfield I'm doing the
wired autocomplete interview let's begin
what Chris Hadfield in the search engine
here we go
what inspired Chris Hadfield to become
an astronaut the first people to walk in
the moon when Buzz Aldrin and Neil
Armstrong walked on the moon in July
20th 69 I thought if they could do that
I could do that that inspired me what
was Chris Hadfield education I went to a
bunch of different schools but basically
I'm a farmer and mechanical engineer and
a pilot fighter pilot test pilot that's
was my education become an astronaut
what was Chris Hadfield first job I grew
up on a farm but when you growing up on
a farm it's not really sort of a job was
just what you do every day after school
my first real job was working in a
scientific shipping warehouse when a
school ordered scientific equipment I
was the guy back in in the shipping
department that would collect the the
pig fetuses or the the weigh scale put
him in a box and and mail them to your
school that was my first job what did
Chris Hadfield find in space did I find
in space a new way to look at the world
what did Chris Hadfield this is terrible
English what did Chris Hadfield learned
from going blind well I learned better
English from this sensor during my first
spacewalk there was contamination inside
my space they've gotten both my eyes
blinded me what did I learn from that
number one don't panic panic doesn't
really help especially if you're all
alone in space and the second was you
need to do a better job of cleaning the
visor of your space helmet because it
was actually the anti-fog and the visor
that good into my eyes that made me go
in blind so remember if you're doing a
spacewalk clean your visor really
carefully and don't let it get in your
eyes and you probably won't go blind
emerging from below as often Scrolls on
a computer screen these are the
questions that begin with where where
Chris Hadfield where does Chris Hadfield
live I live on earth wasn't always true
but right now I live in Toronto Ontario
Canada and I like it there it's a nice
city it's well-run good place you get a
chance live in Toronto where was Chris
Hadfield born I was born about I don't
know maybe a couple hundred yards from
the US border right on the edge of
Canada in a town called Sarnia Ontario
in Sarnia General Hospital August 29th
1959 makes me a Virgo where is Chris
Hadfield right now on earth I'm in Las
Vegas baby and what happens here falls
on the floor where did Chris Hadfield go
in space I went around and around and
around the world we launched out of
Florida we're actually on my third
flight we launched out of Kazakhstan
just south of Russia you go straight up
for a while then the spaceship turns
over start going faster and faster and
faster parallel to the surface of the
earth so that the whole trajectory of
the spaceship is to go around the world
and if you can get going seventeen and a
half thousand miles an hour five miles a
second 25 times the speed of sound then
you'll stay in space basically forever
you'll just coast once you get there so
that's what I did gotten three different
rocket ships blasted off went around the
world two thousand six hundred and fifty
times so I went on a pretty amazing
world tour more than Keith Richards I
think all right oops all right this one
at risk of putting shadows on my face
says when Chris Hadfield when when Chris
Hadfield let's choose him verb here when
did Chris Hadfield first walk in space I
first walked in space during my second
spaceflight we were on board space
shuttle Endeavour we were building the
International Space Station imagine
you're wearing the most uncomfortable
clothes you've ever worn like like a big
snow suit or something end gloves and a
hat and big boots you can hardly move
you grab on to both sides of the hatch
and you sort of like maybe a chick
coming out of an egg you know you have
to sort of fight your way out but then
you pull yourself out and
you're weightless let go with one hand
and you float around gently the other
way and suddenly you've gone from this
claustrophobic little dark place to now
being surrounded by eternity where the
whole world is silent next to you like
this big magic globe but it's separate
from you but all around you is the three
dimensions of of everything and it's
perfectly black it's it's unbelievable
like you've given birth to yourself into
a whole new place if you get a chance go
on a space walk
when was Chris Hadfield last Space
Flight seven years ago right now I was
onboard the International Space Station
it was 2012 2013 it was so cool cuz I
was up for half a year so we went
halfway across the solar system like we
went from one side of the Sun to the
other while I was on board the ship
pretty neat
watch the whole world like swap ends
what was winter in the northern
hemisphere became spring got to watch
the snow and everything move and things
start turning green the time I was up
there okay when will when will Chris
Hadfield while drum roll please get out
of space I don't even know what that
question means maybe people out there
searching on Google maybe they think I'm
still in space I'm still spaced out well
I know I've been back for seven years
and happily so there's no choices we're
all in space all the time where would I
go space is all around us why Chris
Hadfield all right why is Chris Hadfield
a hero he's not why is Chris Hadfield
important to Canada I was the first
doing several things I was the first
Canadian to do a spacewalk I was the
first Canadian to command a space ship
I was the first one to use the big robot
arm and if you're Canadian you're really
paying attention you'll notice the name
of the robot arm is the canid arm so
there's this great big arm with Canadian
flags on it out in space being operated
by a Canadian with a Canadian flag on
her shoulder for the first time
big ridiculously Canadian moment so I
think that's why I'm important to Canada
white why did Chris Hadfield retire
because I got a Holt look at my hair
because I was never gonna fly in space
again and once you've done all the
things you should do an astronaut it's
time to go do something else why is
Chris Hadfield Space Oddity an odd
phraseology but I get a version of David
Bowie's classic tune Space Oddity which
was a play on the word Space Odyssey and
I played it on guitar and recorded on
the space station and lots of people
have seen it it's actually a really
beautiful song and David Bowie loved my
version of it
which was a huge compliment he said
really nice things which was great why
is Chris Hadfield under the ocean this
you may not know I lived at the bottom
of the ocean for like two weeks because
living at the bottom of the ocean inside
a habitat it's sort of like living in
space inside a habitat it's a good way
to train for the technical stuff but
also psychologically if you can't
immediately come up to the surface if
you have to solve all your problems
yourself it's not a bad psychological
training ground for being an astronaut
so if you see Chris Hadfield under the
ocean
that's probably why what Chris Hadfield
okay let's choose a word what is Chris
Hadfield famous for I think I'm most
famous for strangely enough playing
music I mean I'm an astronaut I've done
spacewalks I was NASA's director of
operations in Russia I intercepted
Soviet bombers off the coast of North
America during the height of the Cold
War but I think I'm most famous for
playing guitar and singing Space Oddity
in orbit I've made a lot of effort to
communicate with people using social
media during my third spaceflight I made
a bunch of videos if I go into any
school around the world they've been
watching those videos sort of as as part
of their science classes the ease of of
Twitter and such allowed me to
communicate with so many people around
the world almost on a one-on-one basis
what is Chris Hadfield favorite color
blue sort of a sky blue it's a nice
place to be color around my eyes
what awards because chris hadfield one
how about a lot of awards in grade 8 I
won the public speaking contest in my
school in grade five I won the posture
contest
I was also the top test pilot at the US
Air Force test pilot school and top test
pilot in the US Navy the award that
actually meant the most to me was as I
was a test pilot they did this really
complicated test to put a hydrogen
burning engine for a hypersonic airplane
out on the wing tip of an f-18 and I
presented at the Society for
experimental test pilots big annual
conference and I won best project for
for being a test pilot for the whole
world and that kind of opened the doors
to get chosen as an astronaut your life
sort of trundles long you'd hit a big
watershed and after that everything
after is sort of the result of one
moment in time or that might have been
the one I'm most proud of one that had
the biggest impact on my life anyway
what is Chris Hadfield it's a little
tiny one what is Chris Hadfield Oh IQ I
don't know but I actually when I was a
teenager I was kind of you know insecure
like everybody and I wanted to join
Mensa the organization of people that
were that had high enough IQs and it
turns out when I did the Mensa test
Mikey was high enough to join Mensa but
then once I join Mensa I didn't really
know what to do next but it at the time
it seemed important all right what
languages does Chris Hadfield speak I
speak English and then I'm from Canada
and so we teach French in Canada a
donkey pollen food for a COC aid and
then as an astronaut I wanted to be able
to fly a Russian spaceship and work with
Russians and so you never do Puerto
sceetos yeah I speak a little bit of
Russian a little bit of German but I've
kind of forgotten all of it how to eat
in space Chris Hadfield well your food
floats for one thing so you don't need a
plate like a plate would be useless so
what you do is you get your package you
either make it cold or hot and there's
just like this little easy bake oven
where you can warm up to package you
can't really cook it might be dehydrated
food and then you slide it over a needle
and you dial and you push a button and
it fills up the package
the right amount of water now you've got
your package and you mix it up and your
velcro it to the wall let it sit soak up
the water and then you carefully slid it
open because if you open it quick you'll
get like a little spooky stuff all over
the room so you don't want that so you
carefully open so nothing comes flying
out because nothing's gonna fall to the
floor and then you get a spoon spoon is
a great utensil and you want a a long
spoon so we can go all the way to the
back of the package and then you eat
everything out of one package
you don't like have peas and meat and
potatoes and corn you just eat all of
your piece first and they have to be
creamed piece they don't float all over
and then you ball it up super tight
because you have to get rid of your
garbage put it in the garbage and then
you open your next thing which might be
I don't know or tortilla so that's how
we eat in space one thing at a time in
its package it's sort of like I don't
know eaten on the bus or eating on a
camping trip or something here's a funny
thing about being in space and that is
because there's no gravity that means
that the stuff in your nose and your
sinuses never drains so it's sort of
like you always have a head cold you
can't really taste your food as much you
know in here like this your food all
sort of tastes bland because you're not
smelling it you're not getting it in
through all of your sensors so food and
space taste sort of bland and the food
that has the strongest spice naturally
in it is shrimp cocktail because we've
got cocktail sauce on which is you know
a lot of horseradish now you wouldn't
think you would have shrimp cocktail in
a spaceship filled with a nice red hot
sauce on it you bite into it it's got
that nice crunch and then you get that
surge of eye watering horseradish
cocktail sauce and for a moment or two
it clears your sinuses so my favorite
space food was shrimp cocktail how to
sleep in space Chris Hadfield first you
have to decide when right because you're
going around the world sixteen times a
day so when is it night it's night every
you know 45 minutes of course you're
gonna get a sunrise every 90 minutes so
you have to cover all the windows so the
Sun doesn't get in your eyes and then
you float into your little sleep pod and
there's a sleeping bag tied to the wall
with a string you you float in carefully
you float into your sleeping bag it's
got arm holes and then you could zip up
your sleeping bag and now you're just
sort of
loading like a fish in an aquarium
inside your sleeping bag you pull the
little doors closed on your sleep pod
you turn the fan down as low as you can
don't want to suffocate but make it
quiet and then you shut off the light
and then you relax every muscle in your
body and your arms float up and your
knees float in your butt waist bends and
your head comes forward and your whole
body's perfectly relaxed and you don't
need a pillow and you never have to roll
over your shoulder doesn't get sore it's
like the most calm and comfortable sleep
you've ever had in your life I think if
we start flying tourists in space it's
gonna be feel like the space spa the
best sleep you've ever had how to meet
Chris Hadfield hmm well let's see I
speak all over the world I'm constantly
traveling I've been millions of people
I don't just hide so if you want to meet
me you could go to my website Chris
Hadfield CA I think and see when I'm
gonna be somewhere or you can send me a
note we could eat meat I'm on Twitter
and Facebook and Instagram and such you
could write me a nice letter I'd love to
get a letter from you and if you draw me
a really nice picture I'll stick it up
on my fridge how long was Chris Hadfield
commander of the International Space
Station about two or three months we
take turns and we go up in a little
spaceship or the Russian one the Soyuz
pretty soon we'll be going up and down
on American ships built by Boeing and
built by SpaceX but when I went we took
turns there were new crews every three
months so if you think about it we
rotate who's in charge every two or
three months okay this is a big question
at least you know physically how did
Chris Hadfield contribute to space
exploration well when you're the first
to do things people notice because if
say for example there'd never been a
Canadian who was the mission specialist
which was like a fully integrated crew
member on the space shuttle I was the
first Canadian so that was sort of a big
contribution for the 37 million people
that live in Canada did a bunch of
research while I was up there I helped
run the 200 experiments on the space
station I helped build two space
stations that's kind of a
you know with your hands kind of
contribution but I was NASA's director
of operations in Russia so I helped
helped the space program across cosmos
of Russia and NASA of the United States
work and get along so I contributed
there and I served as an astronaut for
21 years
every single day for 21 years so that
was that was a big contribution as well
this question is unnamed it just has my
name I can open it from right to left
just for variety okay the first Canadian
in space and now we have to choose the
modifier was ah was Chris I'd field the
first Canadian in space no the first
Canadian space was Marc Garneau the
second was Roberta Bondar the third was
Steve McLane I was fourth fourth
Canadian in space very proud did Chris
Hadfield walk on the moon I never got
the chance and we haven't had anybody
walk in the moon since I was 12
soon we will there are their astronauts
training right now and and we're
building hardware right now for people
to not just walk in the moon but
actually start settling the moon start
living there just like we live in
Antarctica or some of the more remote
parts of the world so what's happening
so maybe I'll still get a chance to do
what I dreamed about when I was a little
boy okay here's the next question go to
space with who did who did Chris
Hadfield go to space with I went to
space with Russians and German and
Americans I think but that's all just
kind of arbitrary I went to space with
people from Earth okay one more question
here in the unnamed section and that is
is Chris Hadfield okay yeah thanks for
asking okay
part of what happens in space though is
a lot of things degrade in your body you
lose part of your skeleton your muscles
sort of waste away because there's no
gravity that you have to fight so your
body gets lazy your heart gets smaller
your balance system gets confused
because there's no gravity some
astronauts in fact their eyeballs
because of the change in the internal
fluid pressures of your body their
eyeballs change shape so they see not as
well after they've been in space but
I've been back from space six or seven
years now and my bones are dense my
muscles are strong my eyeballs are okay
everything seems to be alright my
balance systems good so yeah I'm okay
Thanks so that's a lot of questions
about me how about you have any
questions about I don't know astronauts
in general all right oh cool what
astronaut here we go what are the
requirements to be an astronaut
that may be changing right now because
with Elon Musk and Richard Branson and
Jeff Bezos and and other companies
trying to allow anybody who can buy a
ticket to be an astronaut or at least to
fly in space I think that'll be good but
up until now you had to kind of really
be ready to fly a spaceship so if you
want to fly a spaceship what are the
requirements well you need to understand
complicated things like
orbital mechanics how do you maneuver in
space how do you how do you make things
accurately work how does a spacesuit
work or the physiology of the human body
or a little understanding of solar
physics and rocket propulsion systems
and communication systems and being able
to reprogram the computers and plus it's
an International Space Station so learn
to speak some other languages and so
there's a lot of requirements but the
fundamental three things you need are
number one a healthy body that fits in
your spacesuit so not too big not too
small and healthy number two
the proven ability to learn complicated
stuff so how do you know somebody can
learn complicated stuff
choose people with multiple university
degrees who've proven that they can get
a high score on a test or do original
research and then the third people who
can make good decisions so we choose
people who have had complicated jobs
like test pilots and medical doctors
life or death where people have run
programs in my case to become an
astronaut I didn't really know what to
do I'm from a country that doesn't have
very many astronauts but I looked at the
astronauts of the world and the
cosmonauts and I thought okay everybody
needs a university education so I went
to four different universities and I did
it all in technical mechanical
engineering and I thought okay I need I
look at you know Neil and Buzz and Sally
Ride and and everybody and they have
good healthy bodies so okay I need to
keep my body in shape so think about
what I eat and exercise a little bit and
keep myself strong and then I thought
astronauts fly in space you know that's
a verb I can learn to fly I just have to
do it so I started learning to fly when
I was a teen
I joined the Air Cadets they taught me
to fly gliders and then powered
airplanes and then I joined the Royal
Canadian Air Force and flew a bunch
airplanes eventually flew fighters as I
was a sea f-18 pilot and then I went to
test pilot school but the US Air Force
and then was a test pilot with the US
Navy then Canada had an astronaut
recruitment and they hired me to be an
astronaut so so I guessed right I was a
kid
what is astronaut ice cream made of
you've probably tried to ask for an ice
cream it you bite into it and it sort of
melts in your mouth and crumbles it's
like a block of cotton candy I think ice
cream Western and ice cream is mostly
made of sugar like whipped sugar the
secret is we don't actually eat
astronaut ice cream in space it's not
really astronaut ice cream
it's Science Center ice cream because if
you think about when you bite into that
astronaut ice cream it makes crumbs
because it's that hard brittle sugary
stuff and those crumbs would go
everywhere without gravity they they'd
be in your eyes you breathe them they'd
be in the filters so it would be bad
space food what is astronaut centrifuge
when you fly a rocket ship because it's
accelerating through the atmosphere so
hard with the big engines pushing you
you could push back in your chair and
you sort of get crushed by the force of
this rocket F equals MA right force
equals mass times acceleration we've got
that big force and you're a mass so
you're getting accelerated and you feel
that acceleration is like multiples of
your own weight and the big rocket
motors can crush you in your chair with
like four or five times your weight and
when you come back into the atmosphere
and we're letting the air slow us down
you can get crushed like with eight
times your weight which is really brutal
but how do you get ready for that well
what we do is we get in a little
simulated spaceship and that's on the
end of this huge arm and it spins us
around and around and around until we're
getting pinned against the outside of
this little thing and then we have to
operate the spaceship and show we can do
what we're supposed to do this thing is
called a centrifuge depending on on how
you operate your capsule coming home
if you mess it up
and you're gonna pull a whole bunch of
gee you're gonna crushed a lot and you
have to wear the the result of your
mistakes so it's a really good
reinforcing place to Train what kind of
music do astronauts like astronauts come
from everywhere we like all the music
there is we actually disagree about
music on board this astronaut likes
music that has a melody that stays in
your head and words that mean something
and there's lots of astronauts who are
musicians we keep musical instruments up
on the space station there's a guitar up
there there's a ukulele there's a
keyboard powered by batteries so when
we're relaxing in the evening or when
it's somebody's birthday or when it's a
holiday then we get together with the
instruments on board and and play music
it's just like you do on earth the next
questions are where we're asked you're
not where I think it's gonna say do know
where is where is astronaut training
astronaut training for the United States
is primarily at the Johnson Space Center
in Houston Texas are just outside of
Houston and then in Russia it's at the
Yuri Gagarin cosmonaut training center
but then we also train in Canada at the
Canadian Space Agency on the outskirts
of Montreal and we train in Europe in
Germany at the European astronaut Center
which is just outside of Cologne Germany
and then also in Japan because it's an
International Space Station so
everyone's got their own training and
that one is in a little scientific
training town called scuba all around
the planet where astronauts feel the
atmosphere begin that's cool you're
floating weightless in space you turn
your spaceship around backwards because
you're going around the world in this
perfect circle and you fire your big
engine for like maybe four minutes and
it changes you're perfectly circular
orbit into kind of like an oval where
there's a low part nano and a high part
and that low part of your oval starts to
just touch the top of the atmosphere
like like if you stuck your hand out the
window of the car not going too fast you
can just feel a little bit of air
pressure but you're going so fast where
you're going five miles a second so even
a tiny little bit of air really starts
to slow you down
and when you feel the top of the
atmosphere the only way you can really
feel it like is if you
hold your checklist up and you let go of
it and instead of just floating in front
of you it now starts to gently fall
towards the floor everything starts to
behave like a feather and you're still
kind of just hardly sitting in your seat
that you're strapped into but with every
passing second you start to see the
effects of gravity more and more and we
sort of really call atmospheric entry
about four hundred thousand feet up we
call that entry interface that's where
you start to feel the atmosphere begin
and if you look out the windows of the
spaceship you can see that they're
starting to get hot and as you come in
it gets hotter and hotter and there's
flames pouring all around until if you
can imagine that you were somehow inside
a blast furnace and the red and yellow
flames are ripping all around your ship
as that that huge deceleration is
causing all the friction and pressure
and drag that's that's what the
atmosphere does to you a little later
but the early wispy atmosphere 400,000
feet where astronauts hang out huh at
the space bar yeah standard jokes well
we have to live near our training
equipment so most astronauts live close
to the Yuri Gagarin cosmonaut training
center in Star City Russia or the
Johnson Space Center in Houston Texas
there's a few obvious favorite places
nearby to those space centers where
where we go in the evening there was one
classic called the outpost which was
close to the Johnson Space Center and it
had all sorts of sort of contraband
paraphernalia old astronaut pictures and
sign pictures and stuff people had
brought back from space and stuck to the
wall in this crappy old firetrap of a
building eventually the fire inspector
said now we you know we need to be
grown-up about this and the outpost got
torn down but for a lot of years that's
where the astronauts hung out at the
outpost these next questions by popular
demand started with why why astronauts
never cry in space well it's not because
we're not sad actually sometimes you cry
because you're happy and what I found
actually it's such a rich experience
that my emotions were closer to the
surface the whole time I found myself
laughing and crying way more often than
I do on earth but you can't
really cry without gravity gravity
pushes the weight of the tears down out
of your eye well without gravity then
the tears are not gonna get drain out of
your eye in fact they're just gonna stay
in your eye until you can't really see
properly and then you need a hanky or
something to dry your eyes now if you
watch the movie gravity I think when
when Sandra Bullock was crying somehow
her tears were propelled across the
spaceship her tears were squirting
across the room I don't know anybody who
cries like that in space tears don't
fall why
astronaut not use pencil in space that's
not true we do we use pencils in space
all the time pencils don't care where
where gravity is you can write up you
can write down you can write sideways so
we use pencils all the time we use
grease pencils because grease pencils
are really tough we use sharpies
sharpies work great ballpoint pens don't
work too well because you know take a
pen and write upside down for a while if
your pen won't write upside down like a
lot of them do then it's not going to be
a good pen to use in a place where
there's no gravity I don't have a
Sharpie but if I did I would cross oh
not why astronaut use pencil in space a
little bit of a caveman phrasing but we
use pencil in space because pencil work
all right
why do astronauts exercise in space
being in space is the ultimate lazy
existence it's the ultimate place for a
couch potato you don't have to fight
gravity you don't have to lift a finger
you don't have to hold your head up
everything just floats nothing sags it's
a great place to be but as a result of
the fact that you don't have to fight
gravity you can be super lazy even your
heart gets lazy because it it doesn't
need to lift the blood from the bottom
of your feet all the way up to the top
of your head it just has to push it
through your blood vessels your heart
actually gets smaller your muscles would
waste away you wouldn't have this big
skeleton fighting gravity so your
skeleton would dissolve so we have to
exercise in space because we're coming
home again and we don't want to come
back as like you know jellyfish so we
exercise about two hours a day on the
spaceship we have a stationary bicycle
no seat because you don't need a seat
it's more like
I don't know a unicycle without a seat
and then we have a treadmill that we can
run on and there are big elastics that
we wear on our hips and our shoulders to
hold us down on the treadmill so we can
run and pound away and then we have a
resistive machine you can't lift weights
because you're weightless so between the
treadmill and the bicycle and the reason
system exercise 2 hours a day you want
to be conscious of your own sweat when
you're weightless and so what we do is
we keep a towel nearby and if you're
good you can take the towel and just
float it there in space next you and you
workout for a while until you get in the
sweaty and then you dry the sweat off
and so your towel becomes sort of
disgusting after a while and then you
just velcro the towel to the wall and
the sweat evaporates out of it it
becomes humidity inside the spaceship
that's collected in the dehumidifier and
it's turned back into drinking water and
getting onboard your sweat becomes
becomes what you drink
the next day yes long as you have a good
purifier it works all right I came home
the same weight is what I launched but
with 20% less fat
so 20% more muscle so it was good came
back kind of ripped it was ok and my
cardiovascular was good but I didn't
keep the bone density up the bone
density and my hips and my upper femur
had I lost about eight and a half
percent of my bone which is a lot and so
you running a big risk of breaking your
hip when you get back until your body
goes whoa I'm back on earth and starts
to build dense bones again why do
astronauts go to the moon well so far
only 12 astronauts have walked on the
moon 24 astronauts have gone to the moon
a lot of them just orbited it they
didn't walk it's not like a lot of
astronauts have kinds of the moon but
why do astronauts go to the moon we went
because in May of 1961 President John F
Kennedy stood up and said we choose to
go to the moon that's why we went it was
a form of cold war between the United
States and the Soviet Union it was proof
that we could it was to challenge the
the whole industrial capability of the
United States like why climb Everest
challenge yourself see if he can do it
make it part of who you are but now that
we've done it why go back to the moon I
think now it's just like all exploration
first prove that you can do it and then
make it part of the
experience eventually we'll go to the
moon to stay and live just like
everywhere else why do astronauts train
underwater how do you simulate being
weightless I mean sitting here in this
chair I'm being crushed down all the
time so it's a lousy simulation of
weightlessness now we could all ride in
the back of an airplane and have the
airplane push over and have us all sort
of float for a second in the back or if
you got the airplane going like this if
you could float for maybe 20 or 30
seconds and we do that because it's it's
good for little short experiments but if
you really want to Train like for a an
eight hour spacewalk you can't do it in
little 20-second segments so we decided
a long time ago let's let's train
underwater and we'll use the buoyancy of
the water and then the weight of the
suit to balance out and then it's sort
of like being weightless it's not of
course because if you go upside down in
the water the blood still rushes to your
head and you have the drag of the water
moving through the water is way
different than moving through the
emptiness of space it's it's like you
imagine how big a normal Olympic
swimming pool is and then make it 45
feet deep that's what the space station
swimming pool training pool is like we
call it the neutral buoyancy laboratory
all right
how how astronaut how many astronauts
have walked on the moon well it started
with a Neil and Buzz it ended with
Harrison Schmitt and jeans sermon
Cernan so that's four and there were
eight others in between Apollo 11 12 not
13 because they had problems in the
weight of the moon 14 15 16 and 17 so 12
human beings have walked in the middle
brave guys how astronaut communicate in
space we talked to each other on board
the spaceship and people are from all
over the world so you have to choose a
common language the majority of the
International Space Station was built by
english-speaking people and
russian-speaking people so on board we
speak primarily English but lots of
Russian to sort of in a mixture of both
is such as yoga voodoo Petroski but the
Muslim will in the keep our genus Dancy
so I had to learn to speak Russian
because I was a member of a crew onboard
the space station and the cosmonauts
equivalently learned to speak
English but that's just amongst
ourselves we have to talk to earth so
here's what you do you grab the
microphone in the space station or you
push a little transmit button on the
wall and your voice goes through the air
to a little microphone on the wall the
microphone turns into an electric signal
that then goes through the wires to a
little digital thing that turns it into
a digital signal and then that goes
outside of the ship to a big antenna and
we send it up to a geostationary
satellite twenty you know two thousand
miles away from the earth and it
collects that signal from us and then
redirects it down to a great big dish
antenna somewhere on the planet like the
ones in in New Mexico and then they
collect that little digital faint signal
and then they take that digital signal
to send it through wires across the
United States and it gets to the Johnson
Space Center in Houston Texas where
there's another little machine that
takes a digital signal and turns it back
into sort of a analog signal and then it
comes through a wire up to a little
speaker that shakes the same way that
microphone did on the space station and
moves the air molecules and they come
across and goes to someone here and they
hear you how long that takes depends on
how far away we are sometimes we're on
the other side of the world
radio waves go basically at the speed of
light 186,000 miles a second but that's
still you know 186,000 miles it is the
world is 25,000 miles around so if you
got to go all the way out to 22,000 and
back again and maybe even twice it can
take a second or two so when I phoned my
wife from the Space Station it would go
through all of those links and then get
you know through the Houston telephone
system and it would ring on her phone
but the delay was so long that she'd
pick it up and she'd go hello and I go
hello but by the time she said hello and
it got to me and I said hello back to
her it might be three seconds and she
always thought it was like a sales call
and she'd hang up on me so she actually
got the numbers from NASA so that
instead of it coming up as some unknown
number it would say space so her phone
would say space Oh space is calling and
then she'd wait for me to answer the
next question is how astronaut come back
to earth when you say how do you get
back to Earth your real question is how
do you slow down you don't want to hit
the world at seventeen and a half
thousand miles an hour we don't have
enough fuel to just like fire our rocket
and slow down we couldn't bring that
much fuel with us so we just used Frick
we use the drag of the air to slow us
down we just start to fall into the
atmosphere and then once we're in the
atmosphere it catches us and then we fly
the spaceship as carefully as we can to
not have too much drag or too much heat
big s turns all the way down to let
ourselves get aligned and then when we
get close to the earth if your spaceship
has wings like the space shuttle then
you can land it on a runway but if your
spaceship is just a little capsule like
a gumdrop then it would just suck into
the world so we have a great big
parachute or maybe two or three
parachutes and then you can land in the
water which isn't too hard you've done a
belly-flop water can be hard but waters
a little more forgiving than dirt or
rock so you can land your spaceship in
the water and then run the risk of it
sinking or you can have it land on land
and if you're going to land on land you
can use airbags on the bottom and that's
what Boeing is doing now or you can have
little Rockets that just before you hit
the ground they go perfect and fire so
that it slows you down just before you
hit the ground and that's what we did in
my third spaceflight and the Soyuz has
little little retro rockets to cushion
you or as the Russian let's call them
soft landing rockets it's like Greenland
or the Cape of Good Hope you don't
believe the you know the sales pitch
it's a pretty rough landing all right
last questions how do astronauts poop I
don't think you're asking how we poop I
think it's how we use the toilet we poop
like everybody okay I'm gonna get
graphic here for a second how do you
know when you have to poop on earth it's
actually because of the weight of the
poop inside you tells you hey it's time
to poop you know how sometimes you're
lying in bed and you're okay poetry to
stand-up you go wow I really got a poop
well if you're weightless and your
body's not gonna tell you it's time to
poop so you almost have to learn this
new sort of fullness symptom that tells
you it's time to poop you're counting on
gravity because gravity is going to pull
it away from you and without gravity
even when you're done pooping the
there's the poops just going to stay
sort of sticking to you so we wear a
rubber glove and sometimes you have to
like physically separate the poop from
your body but then taking the place of
gravity to pull the poop down into the
toilet is airflow we have air pulled
down into the toilets got
fans in it so and that works for the P
as well so when you want to poop on the
space station then you you wait till
it's your turn in the toilet because
there's a limited number of toilets on a
spaceship two four six people go into
the toilet it's look we have it's sort
of like a little closed off area take
your pants off completely because you
don't want them floating around when
you're on the toilet and then you sit on
the toilet and it's got you could either
hook your toes under some toe loops so
that you don't float off the toilet or
on the Space Shuttle we had sort of like
a little seatbelt thing that claimed
like imagine wearing a seatbelt so you
don't float off your toilet but you
don't want to float off the toilet
partway through it be a mess then you
turn the toilet on great loudest thing
on the spaceship because of all those
big fans to pull the air down into the
toilet and then you pee and poop just
like you do everywhere and the pee goes
down into a sewage system that has
purifiers and filters and gets turned
back into drinking water again just like
on earth except it's not quite as
personal on earth and then your poop
though goes down and gets pulled inside
a tank it looks like a big milk bottle
on the space station when you're done we
use wet wipes because you don't have a
sewage system so you don't have to use
toilet paper get yourself nice and clean
everything goes in there and then it
goes down inside the toilet and then you
clean up for the next person you put the
lid on the toilet and when the milk-can
is completely full of poop then we seal
it with these great big knurled knob
dogs on the top so that none of the
smell will come out then we store it
down in sort of a cold storage area in
this station and then when one of the
unmanned ships comes up with all the
food and supplies and scientific
equipment and then we fill it with all
of our garbage including our solid waste
or our poop and we seal that up and then
when it undocks it separates from the
station and and we fire it down into the
atmosphere and then it it burns up in
the atmosphere so the next time you wish
on a shooting star think about maybe
what you're looking at I'm Chris ad
field thank you for being part of my
wired autocomplete exercise I hope you
learned a few things about spaceflight
and maybe a little bit about Chris
Hadfield astronaut